Have you ever felt that the rich are more arrogant and selfish?
Well, we have decided that the time has come to see if the rich, really, are more likely to become villains.
Did it happen that you were taken while driving? Most likely this was by Mercedes driven by a 20-year-old man.
Multiple studies have found that the higher the cost of a car the more likely it is not just to skip other cars
But also driving through the footpaths when pedestrians are waiting to cross.
One study showed that those with the most expensive cars were walking 42% of the time.
Now, imagine that you waited in line for 10 minutes to buy coffee and cakes at Starbucks
But when I became a few blocks away, I realized that the employee gave you $ 20
Instead of the $ 10 you provided him.
Do you: a) Enjoy your coffee and keep $ 10 extra
Or b) return your drawer and return the money?
The richest people seem to answer that they will keep money.
Also, how much money you own affects how you look at others.
In a study, using Google glasses to track eye movements of people walking in a neighborhood
Rich people spend much less time exchanging social views.
In other words they are more likely to ignore others.
But the rich are certainly more generous with the poor, right?
Although the rich may get a bigger check
In the United States, survey data at the national level show that the wealthy contribute less to their family income.
For example, for a US family whose income is less than $ 25,000, they donate about 4.2% of their income.
While households with incomes of $ 100,000 or more contributed only 2.7%.
As well as the arbitrary baptism or arbitrary granting of power to persons,
Making them more selfish.
Imagine that you put in a group of 3 people to make some important policy recommendations,
You were told that you are in charge of the group.
Place in front of you a dish with 5 delicious cakes. Of course everyone takes one. Do you take another?
It turns out in studies that the person in charge has a greater likelihood of taking the fourth cookies
While everyone leaves the last one in the dish to be more polite.
So do the more rude people become more inclined to become rich?
Or is riches making you worse?
Contrary to what we believe, people are more likely to get power in a group
They are, in fact, emotionally intelligent, who focus on others, be generous, and do not bully.
Studies found that university students at the top of the social pyramid
Tend to be socially positive, sensitive, and not ananine.
This is due to our roots in hunting and assembly, as individuals who share food and resources rise in ranks.
But this leads to a paradox of power.
For power, you need empathy.
But once you feel strong, you become more self-centered.
You can even see it in the brain when using MRI.
Areas such as the prefrontal cortex that are active when understanding mental states or taking into account the thoughts of others
Less activity appears in people with higher social status.
The poor also have a greater ability to assess the emotional state of others
They have higher interactions between people
They are more connected to the eye, gesture, and laughter.
Compared to the wealthiest people, who are more interested in improving their appearance, meditation, or drawing.
One possible explanation for this is that people with fewer substances
Depend more resources and privileges on others to meet their needs,
This creates pressure on them to be more emotionally intelligent.
And of course not all the wealthy are the villains.
But in general, the more your wealth is, the less sympathy you have.
Making statistically rich people more likely to be bullies.
In today's video
We have cooperated with
Audible, which shows everyone who watches this video an opportunity to try it for free for 30 days
All you have to do is visit audible.com/ASAP
Or send a text message asap to 500 500
Download the first address and start listening.
Listening is the best way to end the content you love while doing the things you love.
The Audible has the largest collection of audio books on this planet here.
Such as our recommendation for this day, which is the influential book of mind by Tali Sharot.
He discusses how data is not always the best way to change someone's mind
Instead, it examines the mechanism of our minds when we are opinions or try to make audible arguments.
Audible allows you to switch seamlessly between devices whether your car, tablet, or phone.
Will always keep you informed of the last place you left off.
This is audible.com/asap or an ASAP 500 500 text message
Thanks again and always for watching, and we'll see you next Thursday in a new science video.
Translation: team translate @autrjim